One day, the last star will die and the universe will turn dark forever.
It will probably be a red dwarf.
A tiny kind of star...
...that's also one of our best bets to find alien life...
...and might be the last home of humanity before the universe becomes uninhabitable.
So, what do we know about them?
And why are they our last hope?
At least 70 percent of stars in the universe are red dwarfs.
They are the tiniest stars out there...
...with only about 7 to 50 percent of the mass of our sun.
Not that much bigger than our planet Jupiter, which is still huge though.
Life on Earth has existed for about four billion years.
And we have about a billion years left before the sun becomes so hot...
...that complex life on Earth will become impossible.
We will either die out or leave Earth and look for a new home.
We could build a civilization for potentially trillions of years...
...around a red dwarf with the right conditions.
About five percent of the red dwarfs in the Milky Way may host habitable,...
...roughly Earth-sized planets.
That would be more than four billion in total.
Anyway, it's going to be a long time before the last stars in the universe vanish.
It's kind of uplifting to know...
...that if humanity succeeds in venturing into space,...
...we have plenty of time before the universe turns out the lights.